hey look out the window  welcome to my party guys  [Music]  thank you so much for having us this is  my chance to reconnect with the girls  did mom shoot someone's face this little  bump right here that's you  i still miss her every day  what's that there's something crossing  up the head  keep the girls in the car stay in the  car okay just stay in the car  yeah  okay what's he saying diabolo means  devil  i've never seen anything like this  multiple attacks  without eating a spray  lies don't do that  at least no lion i've ever seen  [Music]  go back to the calls  breathe slow down  we're in his territory now  it's the law of the jungle  it's the only law that matters  i need you to trust me right now  i'm coming back  don't you move  okay  where'd he go  [Music]  you